all right I got to do this interview I
love you soon super excited about
today's dailyvee pretty interesting day
I was looking at the schedule there's
not a lot of places you can go today
I've got like they're not letting you go
to that three hour you know advertising
commit Council I got an advertise it I'm
on the Ad Council and there's this
client meeting now that's not happening
like so I'm you know what I feel I feel
an epic ramped I feel like I have to do
a [ __ ] grant so I'm gonna get spirits
we'll see what happens today I can't
figure out what though know where this
is going I'll see you like I don't give
a [ __ ] if you think I'm the greatest and
[ __ ] the Messiah or if you think I'm
a piece of [ __ ] con artist I'll see you
[Music]
when I did well Kelly is that I figured
out what I had to do which was I needed
to be accountable to somebody else
besides myself if I can say anything to
anybody listening right now I genuinely
believe this is a binary game either you
keep yourself accountable or you're
gonna be accountable to somebody else I
think a lot of people that struggle with
fitness and health and fitness and
really probably in life in general in
different disciplines is they're unable
to be accountable to themselves and and
honestly the reason I think I'm good at
business is because I'm accountable to
other people if you think about my life
I went right into my family business I
was doing it for my family and then I
was doing it for my brother and then I'm
now even my you know back to you stream
I was doing it for you even now with the
I'm doing it for them like I'm always
doing it for somebody else that's my
natural state I even seen in my two
children that's how my little guy Xander
is gonna be he thinks about his sister
first then himself it's just my default
and so but in health there was nobody
else to do it for so I figured out that
I needed a full-time health person that
was not my full-time trainer that was my
full-time health person meaning they've
only worked for me period end of story
that I would make that big financial
commitment and that I would be
accountable to that person so I called
Mike I said can you know somebody and he
said what I would do it I go whoa you're
gonna give up all your other stuff he's
like yeah it's worth it I want to build
an online business I'll do it with you
and so that's what started no
alternative
like like here's the punch line like
like you know I love when people like I
don't care what you think whether you
think I'm right or I'm wrong all of this
advice is only what's you know first of
all you need to know yourself this is
what works for me
I only want people to use me as a proxy
you don't have to do it my way do you my
definition of an entrepreneur
my definition of doing it right my
definition of legacy it's my definition
but here's here's the here's the
punchline
nobody's gonna feel sorry for you
like like like who's gonna feel sorry
for you you I'll tell you who's gonna
feel sorry for you oh oh you don't feel
sorry for you your other enabling losing
players around you it's just one [ __ ]
losing circle like like I mean like
either you're hanging out with people
that are dragging you down or you're
hanging out with people that are lifting
you up and I promise you this every
winner in your life has zero sympathy
for you you know I mean I don't I don't
know what everybody like you're gonna be
90 and you're gonna look back and what
like like what like you know this is it
like that you know and so I mean there's
just so much complaining there's so much
cynicism there's so much you got lucky
there's so much everybody just wants to
point at other people when your [ __ ]
self it's funny kill I don't know if
you've been paying attention but I've
been very hot on self awareness for the
last year and I've been talking a lot
about it but it's funny and I just feel
into my soul right now I'm really gonna
start I can feel it emerging we need to
talk more about the people people
surround themselves with it's a it's a
big one and I'm you know where I'm
seeing it I'm seeing it around my people
I'm seeing around my team like it's so
crazy when I think about Nate my fort
and Phil and d-roc even like I've thrown
this out in the past like it's fun for
me to watch them go from whatever they
are to over a period of time more
confident more accountable harder
working like even with some of them like
they start becoming a little cocky and I
start like laughing like it really it
really matters I'm not worried about
anybody buying anything like I know what
I'm doing here am I my purpose is very
simple I'm capable of making tons of
money building businesses I don't need I
don't need the personal brand part of it
I need people to start doing [ __ ] and
sending me emails like you know what I
need I need the way you started this
show which is my work on social media
seven years ago inspired you to do [ __ ]
and your life is better because of it
talk soon bye bye
yeah I mean you know before I go into
this next call which is right now so
I'll talk like I don't care what I say
and I don't care what comments you're
leaving like at the end of the
difference what I'm doing at the end of
the day it's gonna be what its gonna be
like like it all comes down to 20 30 40
years from now like what like whether
you're vlogging every day whether nobody
knows who you are cuz you're in your
home and you don't say a single thing on
social
it's just results how do the people
around you feel about you how much did
you create what impact did you have on
people what impact did you have yourself
your family it's all these things
work-life balance
financial I loved when people just take
micro shots let me just wrap it up for
you all here like it's full of it it's
the money
it's the fame it's the impact you've had
on people it's the way your family
thinks about you it's the way your best
friends think about you it's your
nonprofit work it's the legacy you left
on others it's how you inspired people
it's how did you make yourself feel it's
what do you accomplish it's all of it
legacy is all encompassing it's not just
how much money my legacy is not that I
made a lot of money about the Jets my
legacy is that unlike every other
business person I know today I'm gonna
do that and I'm gonna impact tens of
millions of people to have a better life
than they would have had had they not
crossed my path what do you think about
the cap
both both you can have both you can be a
[ __ ] ninja entrepreneur [ __ ]
hardcore capitalist until [ __ ] the
[ __ ] biggest business in the world
and you could be an awesome person and
give back to society at scale for the
people that don't have it is easy you
can inspire them you can give them you
can help them you can do but if you've
got the talent like the [ __ ] you guys
think is happening here I can do both oh
you know
I just don't understand what people
think you know
it's not it's not even that it's just
like both like I'm gonna do it all like
like I don't care what do you think I'm
gonna do or not or like like I'm like I
get that you're seeing one video and you
think I'm all about like you know like
one person asked that question like how
do you measure I'm like money that was
in the context of business in that one
second you'll see like you don't see me
at the nonprofit conferences and things
that you don't see what I do for my
friends bonuses you don't see how I'm
raising my children you'll say I get it
I don't I get it but else but I'll see
you like I know where this is going I'll
see you like I don't give a [ __ ] if you
think I'm the greatest and [ __ ] the
Messiah or if you think I'm a piece of
[ __ ] con artist I'll see you
I [ __ ] see you
I'll see you in 2020 2030 2040 2050
everybody thought I was just a [ __ ]
wine retailer twittered then I was just
Twitter boy then I was this like I'll
see you like it doesn't matter what we
think today
matters what everybody thinks when it's
over
I plan on [ __ ] winning straight up
with your support or your disdain I'm
gonna [ __ ] win
sit because I'm gonna do both so I'm
gonna appease you capitalists and
[ __ ] nonprofits and [ __ ] team
human and team business publicans of
Democrats [ __ ] winners and losers I'm
gonna put these all you [ __ ]
hey scary
[Music]
hello Ryan yeah I uh I got it up sleep
this is a good opportunity in the middle
of this episode too but uh this whole
like me ranting with you guys are like
how much motivation do you want don't
watch me I just wanna give some clarity
on it it's much more theoretical meaning
meaning I know some people watch cuz
it's entertaining or it's fun or it's
your escape is Amaya watch the Jets like
we all have that it's I just want it so
bad for you I want it bad for you you
understand
unlike so many people that look like me
put out content self-absorbed vanity all
those cliche things I know how to make
money outside of you unlike so many of
the Guru's and the experts I don't make
my living off of extracting money out of
you
you've got to wrap your head around this
my currency my payoff my nut that I'm
trying to get off here is the email from
you that I was the one that brought you
the value that got you to do something
good so when I'm frustrated and I'm
telling you not to watch me anymore and
go do think about how different that is
than everybody who's like I'm not gonna
give you anything and oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you little crumbs here and
then Wow look over here
pay me $40,000 a year to get the real
good stuff I want none of that I want
the reverse I'm the reverse like of
course I want you to watch I'm thrilled
that it's escapism for you guys I have
it too I love it your comments I love it
I read every one of your YouTube things
and your Facebook things things comments
you know like I love that but what I
love more if I had to choose for as much
as I need the attention and I star for
and I love the interaction in the
southeast if I had to pick one push
comes to shove 51 to 49 I'd rather you
go
and have the greatest sleep ever and
send me one email in three years saying
it was this video that video that talk
that book that brought you value that's
real legacy that's way more noble I'm
gonna get mine I was getting mine before
this all started remember so that's the
clarity of stop watching me
it's watch me cuz I love it too but not
at the expense of getting what you
deserve getting the most out of life for
you you winning in a world where I know
so many of you aren't as fortunate as I
was to have people around you that
believed in you like my mom and my
friends I want to be that for you I want
to be your [ __ ] cheerleader I believe
that you can and by the way nah I'm not
like anybody can do it like some you
suck something you don't have the skills
why do you think I talk about
self-awareness and the reality of I
don't let self-awareness the reality of
hard work and talent being a real
variable I'm not some [ __ ] like any
money can do it I hate 5th place
trophies like I just want you to try
hard that the thing that you may
naturally be best at because that's
where everybody finds their moment and
not everybody supposed to be number one
but if you're destined to be number
87,000
and then 843 million
are you able to come in thank you know
I think because what I'm selling and
pontificating about is very very human
and not demo or age or demographic you
know it's kind of it's really simple I'm
not I'm not selling anything to anybody
other than showing people and
documenting how I'm going about it and
really what I think I'm pressing is
legacy and self-awareness and and you
know recognizing that it's only one that
bad and I think I'm think I'm pounding
home very tried and true things that I
believe in I think I think maybe that's
you know it's funny on this on the app
in here maybe that's what's working for
me I so believe geez I still believe in
what I'm saying you know and I think I
think that that resonates with people of
all ages you know whether one agrees or
disagrees I do think it's important for
people to feel like that somebody's
intent is in the right place and I
believe that my intent is catching
people's attention because it genuinely
is you know my big payoff here is the
email of thanking me is the tweet of
admiration that I did something for them
with nothing in return and so I feel
guilt that people are giving me their
time and attention and I don't take that
for granted and it's very important to
me that while they're watching my video
or listening to the podcast that I bring
them value and I think one of the ways I
bring value is I challenge and high
people to actually do something and a
funny thing happens when you actually do
[ __ ] stuff starts happening and and I
also think I'm a no excuses kind of
character I think something I've been
seeing a lot come through like social
media last month is people saying
whether through watching my daily beat
blog or through
an interaction on Instagram they realize
they weren't working hard or they
weren't really applying themselves for
or they were complaining and I think um
I think people are paying attention
because I think they're getting results
from consuming me and I think that's the
ultimate compliment I need a power
supply with me because I'm really bad
yeah okay no worries no worries no
worries I got your email thank you I
haven't been able dressing it I will I
will since talk
come on how you doing I'm cool on you
were sitting in on anything just half
[Music]
so I'm gonna have dinner with him and
like talk about his nonprofit of his
wife's business so I'll see him soon
like my director sent us videos like hey
just want to like give advice it was
very inspirational and I was like you
know this is really great and like I do
give my all with everything that I do
but I think that like to be successful
it's all about your attitude your
perspective so I was like can we
implement a challenge where there's no
complaining
sure right because it's like toxic and
like it's like a cancer I'd hate using
that analogy like I literally have to
like walk away from people and sales
like it's so crucial to keep off course
because like we said like stupid glass
it's gonna be half empty non pursue no
not half full
that's right he was like I really love
that and I run it by our senior manager
and leadership team I was like cool like
let me do it let's [ __ ] do it I said
of your video so I was playing here you
said it fast okay
Thank You negativity it's louder than
positivity it is unfortunately yeah it
is know it I'm glad we ran into each
other I know I can I met Gary vti thanks
for loving to you take care thank you
you're doing your job thank you bye is
that a dog in the wild dog I found you
you are you know I need I need to talk
to you right now
what are you here I know I've been here
more than sex yes uh what are you doing
that nigga's there he just wanted to see
you tomorrow - thank you this thing oh
yes yeah
today something's I lost a journal
article I heard it I heard it
yeah oh well incredible yeah yeah IMAX
is flying in we're recruiting max me and
forget somebody starts clicking I think
you need early it's the best in
everything all right
that was a super weird amount of stuff
going on the fix I get I'm glad you're
around you rock and and their family
like they're they'll help us they'll
help us get you know higher talent
they'll they're their family okay sounds
good
going inside three more meetings but I'm
gonna send you home dear Rach I'll try
to do a snapchat for you you can use at
the end of this or you can end with me
going to the to the Regency this was a
good one
good [ __ ] day
[Music]